This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《以防万一》节目，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都感觉并不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，收听学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用硬核方式在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O百分之。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约好过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. All right, we love to talk about a lot of wellness topics on this podcast, of course, and you know, science-based tips for general,
相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界何处，很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十多岁的心理学。好吧，我们喜欢在这个播客中谈论很多健康话题，当然，还有你知道的，针对一般情况的基于科学的建议。
holistic betterment, which I enjoy, I think we all enjoy, but sometimes I also like to discuss some of the quintessential, I think, 20-something experiences that we feel we need the answers to. And I'm not just talking about like shallow surface level advice, but some serious kind of like psychological understanding in order to move past what we're going through. The kind of, you know, situations that keep us up at night, that keep us in a thought spiral, that become the center of our world for a while, even if it doesn't seem that important to anybody else. And today is this kind of episode. I want to talk about an experience that I've been getting so many requests on, and that is the experience of developing feelings for a friend. And kind of what goes through our heads,
全方位的改善，我很喜欢，我想我们大家都喜欢，但有时我也想讨论一些我所认为的二十多岁典型的经历，我们需要找到答案。我指的不仅仅是肤浅的表面建议，而是某种严肃的心理理解，以便跨越我们正在经历的事情。那种你知道的，让我们夜不能寐、陷入思维漩涡、在一段时间内成为我们世界中心的状况，即使在别人看来这似乎并没有那么重要。今天的节目就是这样一种类型。我想谈谈一个我收到很多请求的经历，那就是对朋友产生好感。以及我们脑海中经历的历程，
our subconscious mind, our bodies, when we find ourselves kind of suddenly having this, like, romantic tension or feeling for someone, that we've only ever thought about platonically. It's really fascinating to me when this happens, right? Because often we have our friends and we have the people that we are romantically interested in. And it feels a bit like taboo. It feels a bit strange for there to be like a crossover there.
我们的潜意识，我们的身体，当我们发现自己突然对某个人产生这种浪漫的紧张感或感觉时，而我们以前只在柏拉图式的层面上考虑过这个人。当这种情况发生时，真的让我很着迷，对吧？因为通常我们有朋友，也有我们对其产生浪漫兴趣的人。这感觉有点禁忌。在那里产生交集感觉有点奇怪。
And there are so many instances when everything just seems to like kind of take on a new light, right? Like you can't stop thinking about them. You can't stop chasing after them. You can't stop like talking about them and to them. you start imagining a future together and this is somebody who has always been firmly planted in like the platonic category of your mind and i think that it can be very very strange and we have this kind of weird tension between suppressing our feelings and protecting the friendship kind of
有那么多的情况，一切似乎都呈现出一种新的光芒，对吧？比如你无法停止想念他们。你无法停止追逐他们。你无法停止谈论他们和对他们说话。你开始想象共同的未来，而这个人一直坚定地扎根在你心目中的柏拉图式类别中，我认为这可能非常非常奇怪，我们在压抑自己的感情和保护友谊之间有一种奇怪的紧张关系，某种
suffering without unrequited love in silence and just kind of hoping it will go away or saying something and seeing if there is a potential there for a relationship. And within that, we start to have a lot of fears and a lot of doubts and a lot of worries, right? Like, what if we ruin the friendship? What about all the other relationships or connections that exist around this friendship? Are we going to be permanently kind of stuck in this kind of quote unquote friend zone? Are we going to experience rejection? there is a lot to explore today and unsurprisingly, a lot of psychology and science to explain
在无报答的爱情中默默承受痛苦，只是希望它会消失，或者说点什么，看看是否有建立关系的潜力。在此期间，我们开始产生许多恐惧、怀疑和担忧，对吧？比如，如果我们毁了友谊怎么办？与这种友谊相关的所有其他关系或联系怎么办？我们会不会永远陷入这种所谓的“好友区”？我们会经历拒绝吗？今天有很多内容要探讨，毫不奇怪，有很多心理学和科学来解释
this experience, one that feels so personal and vulnerable and unique, but is actually a lot more common. So let's talk about it. We're going to talk about why it is that we fall for our friends seemingly more often than you would think. And what we can do about it. What is kind of the path forward through this maze of feelings. So let's get into it. As I said, falling for a friend is actually not that uncommon. You can breathe a bit of a sigh of relief if you're finding yourself in this situation, knowing that you are probably not the only one. I think it's one of those classic, like romantic tropes, you know, like the meat cutes, the enemies to lovers, forbidden love, childhood sweethearts, falling in love with a friend.
这种经历感觉如此个人化、脆弱且独特，但实际上却要普遍得多。所以我们来谈谈吧。我们将讨论为什么我们似乎比你想象的更频繁地爱上我们的朋友。以及我们能对此做些什么。穿越这片情感迷宫的前进道路是什么。让我们深入探讨吧。正如我所说，爱上朋友其实并不罕见。如果你发现自己正处于这种境地，你可以稍微松一口气，知道你可能不是唯一的一个。我认为这是那种经典的浪漫桥段之一，你知道的，比如转角遇到爱、欢喜冤家、禁忌之恋、青梅竹马，爱上朋友。
A lot of people find love and find connection with those who they initially viewed quite platonically. Even in the world of dating apps and online connections, friendship remains one of those core ways of, I guess, discovering our partner. So back in 2021, a research team at the University of Victoria in Australia, they actually sought to investigate this. we, well, they were noticing that a lot of couples were having the same story, like, oh, we were friends first and then, you know, one day, I just saw them differently. And when you are constantly seeing a particular trend in something like relationship patterns or the way that relationship forms, I think it's worth investigating. And so they talk to over 2,500 people who were married or in de facto partnerships, and they question them separately, and then they question them together. And what they found was that approximately two thirds of these couples started off as friends before they became romantically involved.
许多人与那些最初被他们视作纯洁友谊关系的人找到了爱和联系。即使在约会软件和网络连接的世界里，友谊仍然是发现伴侣的核心途径之一。所以在2021年，澳大利亚维多利亚大学的一个研究团队实际上试图对此进行调查。我们，或者说他们注意到许多情侣都有着相同的经历，比如，哦，我们先是朋友，然后，你知道的，有一天，我就是用不同的眼光看待他们了。当你经常在某些事情上看到某种趋势，比如关系模式或关系的形成方式，我认为这是值得调查的。因此，他们采访了2500多名已婚或事实婚姻的人，他们分别对这些人进行了提问，然后又一起对他们进行了提问。他们发现，大约三分之二的情侣在发生浪漫关系之前都是从朋友开始的。
Two thirds. Now, that does sound like a lot, but you have to remember this also includes people from older generations. And it isn't just referring to the number of people that we date, right? It's talking about the number of, like, who we end up with. So you could be dating heaps of people who you meet on. dating apps. Heaps of people who, I don't know, you met through work or whatever, but the people who we end up together, two thirds of them, the study said, we were initially friends with. What's even
三分之二。现在，这听起来确实很多，但你必须记住，这也包括老一代人。而且它不仅指我们约会的人数，对吧？它指的是我们最终和谁在一起的人数。所以你可能在和大量在网上认识的人约会。约会软件。大量的人，我不知道，你是通过工作或其他方式认识的，但是我们最终走到一起的人，研究表明其中三分之二的人，我们最初是朋友。更棒的是
more interesting is that they looked at how long it took for a friendship to turn romantic in these situations and they found that the average length of time was about 22 months, so almost two years of people going about their days, being nice and chummy and pals and friendly, before kind of like something switched, something flipped in one of their minds. So about 68% of these participants reported that their most recent relationship as well before this relationship also began as a friendship. And this was regardless of gender, age, education levels or ethnicity. it's showing that I think that really accounts for the people that we date and do not marry.
更有趣的是，他们研究了在这些情况下友谊变成浪漫关系花了多长时间，他们发现平均时间约为22个月，也就是差不多两年的时间里，人们过着自己的日常生活，友善、融洽、友好，然后某种东西发生了转换，其中一人的脑海中发生了翻转。因此，约68%的参与者报告说，在这段关系之前的最近一段关系也是从友谊开始的。这与性别、年龄、教育水平或种族无关。这表明，我认为这确实解释了我们约会但不结婚的人。
It's less than the two-thirds, but it's still quite significant that we are finding connection through friendship. And that rate of a friend's first initiation was even higher amongst 20-somethings, like you and I, I'm assuming, and within LGBTQIA-plus communities, with 85% of couples in this community saying that their romance began as a friendship. This number is surprising, but I think less so when we think about the principles of attraction and what actually drives our romantic choices and our romantic interest in someone. It really comes down to three factors, proximity, similarity and reciprocity.
它比三分之二要少，但仍然非常重要，我们通过友谊找到了联系。在二十多岁的人群中，比如你和我，我假设是这样，以及在LGBTQIA+社群中，这种朋友先于恋人的比例甚至更高，该社群中85%的情侣表示他们的浪漫关系始于友谊。这个数字令人惊讶，但当我们考虑到吸引力的原则以及真正驱动我们的浪漫选择和对某人的浪漫兴趣的因素时，它似乎就没那么令人惊讶了。它实际上归结为三个因素：邻近性、相似性和互惠性。
These are the factors that really determine the start of a friendship, but they also determine the start of a relationship. They underline all forms of attraction. So let's break these down. I think sometimes it feels a bit strange to like analyze something as beautiful and magical as love through a scientific or an experimental lens, but a lot of our dating choices do come down to our internal psychology. So in research conducted back in the late 90s,
这些是真正决定友谊开始的因素，但它们也决定了关系的开始。它们构成了所有形式吸引力的基础。让我们来分解这些。我想有时通过科学或实验的镜头来分析像爱这样美丽而神奇的事物会觉得有点奇怪，但我们的许多约会选择确实归结为我们的内在心理。所以在90年代后期进行的科学研究中，
this group of scientists kind of noticed that we are more likely to like someone and express admiration and respect for them if we perceive that they are similar to us. So it's the age-old saying that kind of like birds of a feather flock together. And it seems scientifically quite true. If someone shares similar values to us, similar interests, beliefs, hobbies, even educational background, the same kind of cultural family upbringing, we are more likely to fall for them because it gives us more touch-point. or opportunities for connection,
这群科学家注意到，如果我们觉得某人与我们相似，我们更有可能喜欢这个人，并表达对他们的钦佩和尊重。所以这是一句古老的俗语，物以类聚，人以群分。而且这在科学上似乎非常真实。如果某人与我们有相似的价值观、相似的兴趣、信仰、爱好，甚至教育背景，相同的文化家庭背景，我们更有可能爱上他们，因为这给我们提供了更多的接触点。或建立联系的机会，
gives us more conversation topics, and therefore more opportunities for vulnerability and eventually attraction. This is simply known as the similarity attraction effect. We like people who are like us because they feel safe, they feel comfortable, they feel familiar. And there are fewer kind of opportunities for tension,
给我们提供更多的谈话主题，从而有更多的机会进行敞开心扉，最终产生吸引力。这通常被称为相似吸引效应。我们喜欢和我们相似的人，因为他们让人感觉安全、舒适、熟悉。而且这种紧张的机会较少，
I guess, or friction or misunderstanding or having to explain ourselves because this person is so alike or similar to us. It goes without saying that we don't just choose our romantic partners based on similarity, but also our friendships. And so the people that we inevitably become close to in a platonic capacity, therefore kind of have the greatest opportunity to be our best kind of romantic candidates. Right?
我猜，或者摩擦，误解，或者不得不解释自己，因为这个人与我们如此相像或相似。不言而喻，我们不仅根据相似性来选择浪漫伴侣，还根据相似性来选择我们的友谊。因此，那些我们不可避免地在柏拉图式关系中变得亲密的人，因此有最大的机会成为我们最好的浪漫候选人。对吧？
Because if the primary principle behind attraction is similarity, who is more similar to us than the people that we hang out with all the time? Who is someone that we already know that we like and who likes us back? It's our friends and that's why developing feelings for a friend is not as uncommon as we think. Now the other principle comes down to proximity, right? To put it plainly, we are more likely to develop romantic feelings with someone we see frequently and who we are physically or geographically close to. I know this sounds so obvious, right?
因为如果吸引背后的主要原则是相似性，谁能比我们整天厮混在一起的人更相似呢？谁是我们已经知道我们喜欢并且他也喜欢我们的人呢？是我们的朋友，这就是为什么对朋友产生好感并不像我们想象的那么罕见。现在另一个原则归结为邻近性，对吧？坦白说，我们更有可能对我们经常见到且在身体或地理上接近的人产生浪漫的情感。我知道这听起来太明显了，对吧？
We don't, it's kind of impossible to develop true attraction to someone we've never met and we've never talked to. But it's deeper than just having the opportunity for feelings to develop through proximity. It seems that just being around someone or being repeatedly exposed to them increases the likelihood that we will be attracted to them. We also tend to feel safe with people that we see regularly. and so it's likely that a lot of love kind of comes down to the mere exposure effect. So this is a concept that was introduced in the 60s by this, I can't remember his name. Oh yeah, Dr. Robert Zajonic. Zajonk?
我们不会，对一个从未见过、从未交谈过的人产生真正的吸引力似乎是不可能的。但它比仅仅通过邻近性产生感情的机会更深。似乎仅仅和某人在一起或重复接触他们就会增加我们被他们吸引的可能性。我们往往也对经常看到的人感到安全。因此，很多爱可能都归结于单纯曝光效应。这是60年代由这个人提出的一个概念，我不记得他的名字了。哦，对了，罗伯特·扎容克博士。扎容克？
I'll leave it in the description. But he did a lot of work on, once again, the principles of attraction. And it's kind of like quite a reductionist theory, but he basically stipulated, he suggested that anyone can fall in love with somebody else if they're around them enough. And once again, who are we around the most? Our friends. We have a lot of opportunities to make memories with these people. We feel very familiar with their inner workings, their dreams, their quirks, their ideals,
我会把它留在说明里。但他做了很多关于吸引力原则的工作。这有点像一种还原论理论，但他基本上规定，他建议任何人只要和某人在一起的时间足够长，都可以爱上另一个人。再次强调，我们和谁在一起的时间最多？我们的朋友。我们有很多机会和这些人创造回忆。我们对他们的内心运作、梦想、怪癖、理想非常熟悉，
the long conversations that we have, the laughter, all of which are special parts of a relationship, but they also form a bond. a bond that makes someone a great candidate for romance if everything else kind of goes according to plan. This is more likely to be the case when we imagine or we feel like the other person is returning our interest. This is known as reciprocal liking. At first, that may be in the form of friendship, right? Like, oh, I want to be friends with somebody who genuine shows like interest in me and likes me back. But as the bond grows, because they are giving back that energy,
我们进行的长时间对话、欢笑，所有这些都是关系的特殊部分，但它们也形成了一种纽带。如果一切按计划进行，这种纽带会使某人成为浪漫的绝佳候选人。当我们想象或觉得另一个人在回报我们的兴趣时，这种情况更有可能发生。这被称为互惠喜欢。起初，这可能是友谊的形式，对吧？比如，哦，我想和一个真正表现出对我有兴趣并且也喜欢我的人做朋友。但随着纽带的加深，因为他们在回报那种能量，
an investment that we're giving them sometimes our perception can change and so does our interpretation of their actions it's not just they want to hang out with us because they enjoy our company we start to apply a deeper meaning to every little moment and decision and action you know they want to hang out with us it's not just because they're our friend it's because there's something else going on right and so reciprocity is one of those core principles of attraction when we are looking for a mate or someone in love, we want someone who likes us back, obviously, and sometimes we confuse the liking as a friend
以及我们给予他们的投资，有时我们的看法会改变，我们对他们行为的解释也会改变。他们想和我们在一起不仅仅是因为他们喜欢我们的公司，我们开始为每一个微小的时刻、决定和行动赋予更深层的意义，你知道他们想和我们在一起，不仅仅是因为他们是我们的朋友，而是因为还有其他事情正在发生，对吧？所以互惠是寻找伴侣或恋爱时吸引的核心原则之一，我们希望有人也喜欢我们，显然，有时我们把作为朋友的喜欢
as a liking in a romantic sense. All of this kind of creates the recipe for developing feelings for someone that we are friends with. We know we already have admiration and respect to them, otherwise they wouldn't be our friend. We know that we are similar because we are close, that they are familiar and, you know, proximal. and obviously there is reciprocity
混淆为浪漫意义上的喜欢。所有这一切共同构成了一个配方，让我们对作为朋友的人产生好感。我们知道我们已经对他们抱有钦佩和尊重，否则他们就不会成为我们的朋友。我们知道我们是相似的，因为我们很亲近，他们是熟悉的，而且（你知道的）近距离接触。显而易见，存在着互惠，
otherwise the friendship wouldn't have developed in the first place. And so in short, we have fulfilled what a lot of psychologists call the conditions of love just by nature of being platonically close. Now, a lot of what we've talked about that tends to shift liking to loving
否则友谊一开始就不会发展。因此，简而言之，仅仅通过保持柏拉图式的亲密关系，我们就已经满足了许多心理学家所说的爱的条件。现在，我们谈论的很多倾向于将喜欢转变为爱的因素，
really rests in personality similarities, but we're also forgetting about one final thing and that is physical attraction because that is a huge component of any romantic and intimate relationship. And I think it's one of the main reasons why we don't just end up dating all of our friends, right? Like maybe you don't have that kind of sexual preference. Maybe you just don't see them in that way. We can't imagine sleeping with them.
realmente 确实在于个性的相似性，但我们也忘记了最后一件事，那就是身体吸引力，因为这是任何浪漫和亲密关系的重要组成部分。我认为这也是我们不最终和所有朋友约会的主要原因之一，对吧？也许你没有那种性倾向。也许你只是没有那种感觉。我们无法想象和他们上床。
They're not our type. But what about those situations where you've had like no kind of physical attraction for many years? You are firmly in the friend zone. You travel together, you sleep in the same bed, nothing. And then suddenly you start seeing things differently. It happens a lot. And I think the question that we often have is like, has this always been the case? Have I just been suppressing my true feelings in order to protect the friendship?
他们不是我们的类型。但是那些多年来对对方没有任何身体吸引力的情侣呢？你们坚定地处在好友区。你们一起旅行，睡在同一张床上，什么都没有。然后突然之间，你们开始用不同的眼光看待事物。这种情况经常发生。我想我们经常问的问题是：一直都是这样吗？我只是为了保护友谊而压抑了自己的真实情感吗？
Maybe I thought I didn't have a shot. Or it's because we just genuinely didn't experience the physical spark that would make us romantically interested in someone until later. And what is it that changes? Well, let me explain. Each of us has a very unique set of preferences around what we would like, physically in a partner, or at least what we know we would find appealing. So a new study has suggested that beauty, attraction is very much in the eye of the beholder.
也许我以为自己没有机会。或者是因为直到后来，我们才真正体验到让我们对某人产生浪漫兴趣的身体火花。是什么改变了呢？好吧，让我来解释一下。我们每个人对在伴侣身上身体上喜欢什么，或者至少是我们知道自己会觉得有吸引力的东西，都有一套非常独特的偏好。所以一项新研究表明，美、吸引力很大程度上在于观察者的眼睛。
About 50% of our preferences come down to our life experiences. So even identical twins who have the same genetic blueprint, they typically have the same family environment and upbringing, they end up, you know, sometimes dating completely different people because it comes down to things like personal experiences, the media we're exposed to, the people we meet, the things that we're interested in. You know, if you're a very active person, you may like someone who's more lean. If you're obsessed with a particular actor or boy band, you might find yourself having preferences that align with what these people look like, as silly as it sounds. And this also tends to explain why our physical preferences change over time. If it comes
我们大约50%的偏好归结于我们的生活经验。因此，即使是拥有相同基因蓝图的同卵双胞胎，他们通常拥有相同的家庭环境和成长经历，最终，你知道的，有时会约会完全不同的人，因为这归结于诸如个人经历、我们接触的媒体、我们遇到的人、我们感兴趣的事物等因素。你知道的，如果你是一个非常活跃的人，你可能会喜欢更瘦的人。如果你痴迷于某个特定的演员或男子乐队，你可能会发现自己的偏好与这些人长相相符，尽管听起来很傻。这往往也解释了为什么我们的身体偏好会随着时间而改变。如果归结为
down to personal experiences, those things, obviously, you know, we have more of them as we get older. And so it kind of makes sense that our attraction that is derived from personal experiences changes as those experiences accumulate. Perhaps you have had an experience with someone else that shifts how you think about your friend. You have seen them in a new scenario, like on a trip together or at a wedding or at their job and you just see them completely differently, or you're just like physical taste change,
个人经历，这些事情显然（你知道的）随着我们年龄的增长而增加。所以这就讲得通了，随着这些经历的积累，源自个人经历的吸引力也会发生改变。也许你和别人的经历改变了你对朋友的看法。你在一个新的场景中看到了他们，比如一起去旅行、参加婚礼或在他们的工作岗位上，你完全用不同的眼光看待他们，或者你的身体品味变了，
and you haven't seen them in a while, and since that time when you saw them last, they've started dressing differently. They've cut their hair. Suddenly they are exactly your type. And we have this like epiphany moment of like, oh my God, are they attractive? Am I into them?
你已经有一段时间没见他们了，自从上次见到他们以来，他们开始穿不同的衣服了。他们剪了头发。突然之间，他们正是你的菜。我们有这种顿悟的时刻，就像，哦，天哪，他们很有吸引力吗？我对他们有感觉吗？
When we do reach that moment, that kind of place of realization, you're probably going to enter it from the gateway of denial, right? Especially if that is a really valuable and important friendship to you. No one likes to admit something that makes them vulnerable or could drastically change something about their life. It is shocking and it creates an emotional chaos we simply don't want to deal with. So your denial of your true feelings when it comes to your friend kind of comes from a place
当我们达到那一刻，那种意识到自己的地方时，你可能会从否定的角度进入它，对吧？特别是如果这对你来说是一段非常宝贵和重要的友谊。没有人愿意承认会让自己变得脆弱或可能彻底改变生活的事情。这很令人震惊，它造成了一种我们根本不想处理的情感混乱。所以当你对朋友产生真实情感时选择否认，其实是源于
of self-preservation. even if everyone around you is claiming that they can tell you have feelings, that you have a crush that something's changed. Admitting that to yourself and others means, A, giving people information about your personal feelings that might be quite revealing or leave you open to judgment or scrutiny. And B, it requires you to either do something or just endure this kind of possibility of unrequited love until it passes. but if you are regularly checking up on this person on social media, if you are finding that you can't stop thinking about them throughout the day, that you are experiencing a lot of jealousy when they talk about the people they are dating or your territorial over their time, wondering why they aren't texting you back,
自我保护。即使你周围的所有人都声称他们能看出你有感情，你有暗恋对象，事情已经变了。对自己和他人承认这一点意味着，A，向人们提供关于你个人感受的信息，这可能是相当泄露秘密的，或者让你容易受到判断或审视。B，它要求你要么做点什么，要么只是忍受这种单相思的可能性，直到它过去。但是，如果你经常在社交媒体上查看这个人的近况，如果你发现自己整天都忍不住想他们，当你听到他们谈论约会对象时你会感到非常嫉妒，或者你对他们的时间有强烈的占有欲，纳闷他们为什么不回你信息，
always wanting to spend every day with them. If you're changing your appearance when you're around them, I think that's a pretty good sign that something is shifted there. So what are you going to do about? it. I think that's what I want to discuss next, right? Is like, why can this be so difficult to manage? What are the fears that we have to work through? And do we admit our feelings and potentially face not having them reciprocated or ending the friendship in the process? Or do we just say nothing? Do we just see what happens? So I want to talk about all of that and more after this
总是想和他们形影不离。如果你在他们身边时改变了自己的外表，我认为这是一个很好的迹象，表明情况已经发生了变化。那么你打算怎么办呢？我想接下来我要讨论的就是这个，对吧？也就是，为什么这会这么难处理？我们需要克服哪些恐惧？我们是该承认自己的感情，并可能面临对方没有回报或者在此过程中毁掉友谊呢？还是什么都不说？是静观其变吗？所以我想要讨论所有这些以及更多内容，在这段简短的广告之后
short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
休息一下。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O-Persent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小吉姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小吉姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英国。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过它的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为霹雳可卡因。我随时都可以谈论霹雳可卡因，只是为了让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
我在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那件事。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
我们还在追赶。而且我们不知道什么时候做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要？你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
绝对是。那是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart电台应用。搜索《硬核学习》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona? Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Developing feelings for a friend is never the most welcome news. Actually, I think it's a mixture of many emotions, right? Feelings of possibility, the anxiety, the excitement of the what-if, the general, like,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束？在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。对朋友产生好感从来都不是最受欢迎的消息。实际上，我认为它是多种情绪的混合体，对吧？可能性的感觉、焦虑、对“如果”的兴奋、暗恋带来的普遍般的
euphoria and entertainment of having a crush. But we also find ourselves between a bit of a rock and a hard place. what if things change and are never the same? How do we manage our sense of longing? And our typical instinct to really imagine a future with this person whilst ensuring that we don't get ahead of ourselves, doesn't blow up in our faces. We have a very keen sense of what we have to lose. And I think we also understand that it's going to be tricky to navigate. So in those situations where you have become aware of a crush, I guess, you have two options. The first, the first, option is that you can say nothing. This is the path of least resistance. If we say nothing,
欣快感和娱乐感。但我们也发现自己处于进退维谷的境地。如果事情发生变化并且再也回不去了怎么办？我们如何控制我们的渴望？以及我们通常的直觉，即真正想象与这个人有未来，同时确保我们不会操之过急，不会搞砸。我们对我们将要失去的东西有着敏锐的感觉。我想我们也明白这将很难处理。因此，在你意识到自己暗恋上别人的那些情况下，我想你有两个选择。第一，第一，
we don't have to face the possibility of rejection, of loss, of the, let's face it, the awkwardness that might come with them, you know, confirming that our feelings are one-sided. There are a lot of considerations that go into managing our feelings for a friend. And it's not just about them. it's also about of course wanting to protect like your own heart and your own self-esteem but also I think you really contemplate the network of relationships that you have built around this friendship admitting your feelings can create tension in a friendship group because people may start to treat us and other you know the other person differently because of our obvious feelings or confession it becomes a topic of conversation.
选项是你什么都不说。这是阻力最小的路径。如果我们什么都不说，
And then if you were to say something and they say, oh, no, thanks. You might find yourself too embarrassed to be around this larger group who kind of knows that this has happened. The possibility of this presents, I think, a unique type of loss known as social loss. The pain of losing connections as a result of some event. It can leave us feeling alienated, isolated, and worst of all, quite lonely.
我们就不必面对被拒绝的可能性、失去的可能性，说实话，还有当他们（你知道的）确认我们的感情是一厢情愿时可能带来的尴尬。管理我们对朋友的感情需要考虑很多因素。这不仅关乎他们。当然也关乎保护你自己的心和自尊，但我也认为你真的在仔细考虑围绕这种友谊建立的关系网络。承认你的感情会在朋友圈中产生紧张感，因为人们可能会开始因为我们明显的感情或表白而以不同的方式对待我们和其他（你知道的）另一个人。它成为谈话的主题。
As a species, we don't have a particularly good relationship with loneliness. We tend to villainize it, and therefore we seek any alternative, even if it means avoiding our true feelings and, you know, engaging in some good old-fashioned suppression. But if there is, I think, one thing that psychology tells us about suppressing intense feelings or emotions, it's that they find a way to come out, whether that's through resentment towards your friend for not knowing about your feelings, frustration, poor concentration, needing to constantly seek advice and reassurance. I firmly believe that with most things like this, there will come a time when you will need an answer to bring you some peace. you'll need to know whether there is a possibility of this being a thing. And I'm speaking from experience here.
然后，如果你说出来了，而他们说，哦，不，谢谢。你可能会发现自己太尴尬了，无法和这个大群体在一起，因为大家都知道发生了这回事。这种情况的可能性，我认为呈现了一种独特类型的损失，被称为社交损失。由于某种事件而失去联系的痛苦。这会让我们感到疏离、孤立，最糟糕的是，相当孤独。作为一个物种，我们与孤独的关系并不是特别好。我们倾向于妖魔化它，因此我们寻找任何替代方案，即使这意味着逃避我们真实的感受，（你知道的）进行一些老式的压抑。但如果说心理学关于压抑强烈情感或情绪有一点告诉了我们，那就是它们总会找到宣泄的途径，无论是通过对你的朋友因为不知道你的感情而产生怨恨、沮丧、注意力不集中、需要不断寻求建议和安慰。我坚信，对于大多数类似的事情，总有一天你需要一个答案来给你带来一些平静。
I remember having the biggest all-consuming crush on someone in my first year of university who was a good friend. And we were very enmeshed in this friend group together. And I'd formed, it was really my lifeline at the time. This friend group was kind of the first big group of friends I had. In my first early months of moving out of home, they were really important and I spent basically the whole year pining after this person having these small moments that felt enormous at the time constantly wanting more and not knowing where we stood
你需要知道这是否有可能发生。这里我是根据经验在说话。我记得在大一的时候，我对我的一位好朋友产生了最大、最让人全情投入的暗恋。我们在这个朋友圈里紧密地交织在一起。我形成的，那真的是我当时的救命稻草。这个朋友圈算是我搬出家门后的头几个大朋友圈之一。在我搬出家门的最初几个月里，他们真的很重要，我基本上花了一整年的时间苦苦思念这个人，经历那些在当时感觉巨大的微小时刻，不断想要更多，却不知道我们处于什么立场
until I just had to come out and say it and get some answers even though I kind of knew deep down that you know they weren't going to be the answers that I wanted I think it was important and it was really strange for a while I'm not going to sugar. code it right like i remember a lot of those friends like who i was previously friends with because of this person went on like a trip together and like i always felt that maybe if i hadn't made it awkward for people i would have been invited or that they were kind of forced to make a choice between the person who was really deep in their emotions and really struggling and the person who was like the happy one right and who wasn't in a chords drama and as
直到我不得不说出来并得到一些答案，尽管我内心深处有点知道（你知道的）这些不会是我想要的答案，我认为这很重要而且有一段时间感觉真的很奇怪，我不会粉饰太平，对吧？就像我记得那些朋友，（你知道的）我以前因为这个人而和他们是朋友，一起去旅行什么的，我总是觉得也许如果我没有把事情搞得那么尴尬，我就会被邀请，或者他们有点被迫在那个深深陷入情感且痛苦挣扎的人，和那个像快乐的人（对吧）且没有卷入戏剧的人之间做出选择，作为一个
someone who lived through that, got through that, it ends up totally okay. It always works itself out. And I'm really glad that I said something. I'm really glad that even though intuitively I knew that he wasn't going to date me, that we weren't going to have a future together. It was better than spending even more months, maybe even years, stuck in like fantasy and wishful thinking and kind of projecting this big fairy tale I had of him onto the version of him that didn't really exist, right? Like I was only seeing the potential. And I think whilst it remained ambiguous, I could still indulge in the possibility of the what if. But the what if wasn't getting me anywhere. It wasn't doing me any favours. It wasn't allowing me to move on. It certainly wasn't making
经历过那个时期、挺过那个时期的人，结果完全没问题。一切总会自行解决的。我真的很高兴我说了出来。我真的很高兴，尽管直觉告诉我他不会和我约会，我们不会有未来，但这总比再花几个月甚至几年时间陷在幻想和一厢情愿中、把对他的巨大童话般的期望投射到那个实际上并不存在的他身上要好，对吧？就像我只看到了潜力。我认为当这种模棱两可的状态持续时，我仍然可以沉溺于“如果”的可能性中。但“如果”并没有带给我任何进展。它对我没有任何好处。它没有让我继续前进。它肯定没有让我
me a good friend. And it was kind of a relief to hear and be like, no and then we moved forward so saying nothing is one option let me present you with the obvious alternative one that i just talked about i'm sure you've all considered you can muster up the courage to sit this person down and say hey things have changed for me have they changed for you and you can see what they come back with a few caveats here don't do this if they're in a relationship with someone else or fresh out of a relationship. I think that is just like a sign of disrespect to your friend and it's not going to end well. I don't know why I felt they need to say that but in case it wasn't obvious, you still need to respect like have some level
成为一个好朋友，听到并感到宽慰，然后说“不”，然后我们前进了，所以什么都不说是一个选择，让我向你展示显而易见的替代方案，我刚才谈到的那个，我确信你们都考虑过，你可以鼓起勇气让这个人坐下来，说，嘿，我的情况变了，你的情况变了吗？你可以看看他们的回应。这里有几个注意事项。如果他们正与别人交往或者刚结束一段恋情，不要这样做。我认为这只是对你朋友的不尊重，而且不会有好结果。我不知道为什么我觉得有必要说这句话，但以防不够明显，你仍然需要尊重——保持一定程度的
of decency and not just prioritise your own feelings. But besides that, I think being honest about your emotions and being vulnerable, it's not going to destroy you. It's actually probably going to bring you a lot of clarity and make you stronger. The best possible scenario is that they will reciprocate everything you're telling them. They will confess their love. They're down for exploring what this could be. And it grows great. You know, happily ever after baby's marriage, all the good things.
讲究体面，而不仅仅是优先考虑你自己的感受。除此之外，我认为对自己的情绪诚实并展现脆弱，并不会毁了你。它实际上可能会给你带来很多清晰的认识，并让你变得更坚强。最好的情况是，他们会回应你告诉他们的一切。他们会表白。他们愿意探索这种关系可能会发展成什么样。然后感情不断加深，你知道的，从此幸福快乐，结婚生子，所有美好的事物。
You're part of that two thirds of people who end up with a friend. And I think it's almost like a new chapter, right? You already know each other as friends, but then you have to get to know each other as romantic partners. And that may take some time adjusting because it is a whole new level of intimacy. So obviously a lot of... honest conversations about your feelings and intentions hopefully you're on the same page I think even this can be scary even getting like the yes can be scary because what if it doesn't work out
你是那三分之二最终和朋友走到一起的人之一。我认为这几乎就像一个新的篇章，对吧？你们已经作为朋友了解彼此了，但接下来你们必须作为浪漫伴侣去了解彼此。这可能需要一些时间来适应，因为这是一个全新水平的亲密关系。所以很明显，有很多关于你的感受和意图的诚实对话，希望你们能达成共识。我认为即使是这样也会让人害怕，甚至得到肯定的答复也会让人害怕，因为如果行不通怎么办呢？
and you've lost both a good friend and a love interest and a partner that is a particular kind of loss in there I think that's a two in one breakup which would just be so difficult it might also not be completely smooth sailing, right? Like you might sleep together once, be like, I don't know if that's working out, have a bit more of a back and forth, you know you both have feelings together. That is a whole different situation that I think it's so nuanced and difficult because then it's kind of like you have an answer, you know that this person likes you, you like them back, but maybe you're just not meant to work out. Like maybe you're just not meant to be together. And that is the conclusion that you needed to know. At least you gave it a,
你既失去了一个好朋友，又失去了一个恋爱对象和伴侣，这是一种特殊的失落感，我认为这是一个“二合一”的分手，那将会非常困难。事情可能也不会一帆风顺，对吧？比如你们可能睡过一次，然后觉得，不知道这行不行得通，然后经历更多拉扯，你知道你们对彼此都有感觉。那是完全不同的情况，我认为它是如此微妙且困难，因为这就好像你得到了答案，你知道这个人喜欢你，你也喜欢对方，但也许你们注定无法在一起。就像你们可能注定不适合彼此。这就是你需要知道的结论。至少你付出了...
gave it a try. Like at least you, you're not left with the hypothetical. You're not left with the what if. The other scenario is that we are put in the friend zone. Now, the friend zone, I think, is more of a pop culture reference than a scientific term, but it does help to explain what occurs here, in which someone is it communicating that they explicitly see you in the category of friend rather than partner. The friend zone is an interesting concept because it's a lot more common in cross-gender friendships between men and women. And according to some psychologist, the term is used a lot more by men when they have been rejected by a woman who showed no romantic interest in them. In this way, I think it's a bit controversial because a lot of feminist writers and thinkers tend to think of it as
至少你尝试过了。至少你没有留下假设。你不会留下“如果当初”的遗憾。另一种情况是我们被发了好人卡（进入了“朋友区”）。现在，“朋友区”我认为更多是一个流行文化概念，而不是一个科学术语，但它确实有助于解释这里发生的事情，即某人明确表示他们只把你当朋友看待，而不是当成恋爱对象。“朋友区”是一个有趣的 مفهوم（概念），因为它在男女之间的异性友谊中更为常见。据一些心理学家称，当男性被对他们没有浪漫兴趣的女性拒绝时，这个词会被男性更多地使用。通过这种方式，我认为这有点争议，因为许多女权主义作家和思想家倾向于认为它...
like a concept to soothe male feelings of rejection. And it is kind of associated with this idea that men see friendship with women as offering some kind of sexual reward if they are nice enough to them. But when we take away that gender lens, I think the friend zone is really just an assertion of personal boundaries around where people see the relationship kind of existing in the grand scheme and spectrum of relationships. When we confess our feelings, this is often this is an that we don't want. I think it's the fear of rejection that is particularly scary in the situation. Rejection is painful on a social level, but also on a physical and neurological level. The experience of being shut down or pushed away elicits the same kind of reactions we have in
这是一种用来抚慰男性被拒绝情绪的概念。它与这样一种观念有关：如果男性对女性足够好，她们就会把与女性的友谊视为某种形式的性回报。但如果我们抛开性别视角，我认为“朋友区”实际上只是对个人界限的一种坚持，即人们在宏大的关系谱系中看待这段关系的位置。当我们坦白自己的感受时，这通常意味着我们不想要这种关系。我认为在这种情况下，对被拒绝的恐惧尤其令人害怕。拒绝在社会层面上是痛苦的，在身体和神经层面上也是痛苦的。被拒绝或推开的体验会引发与我们在...
response to a physically painful stimuli, like a bee sting, or grazing our knee or breaking a bone. that's because it ignites the same areas of our brains that are responsible for interpreting and processing physical pain. We want to avoid that pain. So when it occurs, when you've been brave, you've put yourself out there and you've been met with a less than ideal answer, the first thing you are going to be feeling is regret, maybe embarrassment, and then probably most likely fear that we've said things we can't take back that are going to be.
面对身体疼痛刺激时相同的反应，比如被蜜蜂蛰、擦伤膝盖或骨折。那是因为它点燃了我们大脑中负责解释和处理身体疼痛的相同区域。我们想要避免这种疼痛。所以当它发生时，当你表现得很勇敢，你表达了自己，却得到了不太理想的回答时，你首先感受到的将是后悔，也许是尴尬，然后很可能是害怕，害怕我们说了一些无法收回的话，这些话将...
permeate and perhaps alter the friendship forever. That's the risk we take in these situations. I think when someone doesn't reciprocate our feelings, it's essentially now an experience of unrequited love. The emotions, the romantic intimacy, that only goes one way. That's particularly hard, I think, because feelings of love are obviously meant to be shared. And it's okay to grieve your idea of what this person could have been, and what you wanted them to be.
渗透并可能永远改变这段友谊。这是我们在这些情况下必须承担的风险。我认为当某人没有回应我们的感情时，这本质上就是单相思的体验。那些情感、浪漫的亲密感，只有单方面的付出。我认为这特别难，因为爱的感觉显然是需要分享的。你可以为自己对这个人的想象以及你希望他们成为什么样的人的逝去而感到悲伤，这是可以接受的。
It doesn't mean that they're still like you in a friendship capacity. Maybe you do need to take some distance for yourself as you heal. That would be my biggest piece of advice is to take a few weeks apart so you can think of a way forward. Even if you can stay friends, I think it's still important to have a bit of like a cooling down period for yourself. To actually think about it and to think about how difficult these unrequited emotions might be and how you're going to manage. I think most of the time we have this impulse to kind of keep face and pretend it doesn't bother us and just like hope everything goes back to the way it was by forcing the same kind of reactions and interactions that we used to have. I would advise against this
这并不意味着他们在友谊层面上仍然像以前那样喜欢你。在你疗伤的过程中，也许你确实需要和对方保持一些距离。我最大的建议就是分开几周，这样你就可以想出一条前进的道路。即使你们能继续做朋友，我认为对你自己来说，稍微冷静一段时间仍然很重要。去实际思考一下，思考这些单相思的情感会有多困难，以及你将如何应对。我认为大多数时候我们都有这样一种冲动：要保持面子，假装这并没有困扰我们，只是希望一切能回到原来的样子，强迫自己做出过去那种相同的反应和互动。我建议不要这样做
because feelings don't disappear the moment they aren't reciprocated. They stay with us and we often have a lot of expectations that maybe this person might eventually change their mind. You have to trust that this person knows what they want and knows what's right for them. Even if it's painful for you, try not to get stuck in the mental loop of questioning their decision, questioning their answer. Is it because I'm not their type? What's wrong with me physically? Am I not good enough?
因为感情不会在不被回应的那一刻就消失。它们会留在我们身边，我们往往抱有许多期望，也许这个人最终会改变主意。你必须相信这个人知道自己想要什么，知道什么对他们来说是正确的。即使这对你来说很痛苦，也尽量不要陷入质疑他们的决定、质疑他们的回答的心灵死循环中。是因为我不是他们的菜吗？我身体上有什么毛病吗？我还不够好吗？
It's definitely a natural line of thinking. We like to overly examine our perceived failures to prevent them from occurring again or to try and come up with some cure or a solution. But often it just gets us stuck in. a pretty deep mental hole, one that is filled with a lot of self-doubt, a lot of insecurity. Just because this person didn't pick you doesn't mean that no one will, but it can be really hard to see that when we're shouldering a lot of deep pain. This is why, again, I recommend giving yourself some space. Let yourself feel disappointed. Let yourself mourn for a little bit
这绝对是一种自然的思考方式。我们喜欢过度审视我们察觉到的失败，以防止它们再次发生，或者试图找出某种治愈方法或解决方案。但这往往让我们深陷其中，陷入一个相当深的心理洞穴中，里面充满了许多自我怀疑和不安全感。仅仅因为这个人没有选择你，并不意味着没有人会选择你，但当我们背负着沉重的痛苦时，要看到这一点可能会非常困难。这就是为什么我再次建议给自己一些空间。让自己感到失望。让自己哀悼一会儿
and then start to think about your future as friends and whether that relationship can be maintained. I think that it's important to try to focus on the friendship that is at the heart of this experience, right? Like, you like them for a reason because they are a good person, but are you going to be satisfied with not having everything, with just having the part that is platonic. That is a question that I think you have to answer for yourself. But while you're thinking it through, I want to give you fun. tips for dealing with this situation from beginning to end. I think when you first notice that you've developed feelings for a friend, stop and pause. Do you actually like this person or are they just
然后开始思考你们作为朋友的未来，以及这种关系是否能够维持下去。我认为重要的是要试着关注这段经历核心处的友谊，对吧？就像，你喜欢他们是有原因的，因为他们是个好人，但你满足于无法拥有一切、只拥有柏拉图式的那一部分吗？这是一个我认为你必须自己回答的问题。但在你深思熟虑的同时，我想从头到尾给你一些应对这种情况的有趣建议。我认为当你第一次注意到你对一个朋友产生了好感时，请停下来暂停一下。你其实是真的喜欢这个人，还是他们只是
the only person around? This is sometimes a very real possibility as the proximity principle tells us. Sometimes all attraction takes is physical closeness to set off a whole chain of reactions. So pause and consider whether this person would actually make you happy in the long term. Whether you are stretching your imagination a little bit too much or whether you are just seeing potential when there isn't anything actually there. Dating in our 20s is really hard. First dates suck. Blind dates are even worse. The constant small talk rejection, the heartbreak, it can feel like a lot.
附近唯一的人？正如邻近原则告诉我们的那样，这有时是一个非常现实的可能性。有时，所有的吸引力只需要身体上的接近就能引发一连串的反应。所以请停下来思考一下，这个人是否真的能让你长期感到快乐。你是否把自己的想象力拉得太远，或者你是否只是在实际上什么都没有的地方看到了潜力。我们在二十多岁的年纪约会真的很艰难。第一次约会很糟糕。相亲甚至更糟糕。源源不断的小对话、拒绝、心碎，感觉压力太大了。
And so sometimes when we've been through a lot of that, we seek comfort in the things that we know. which is this friend that we know will never harm us. But it doesn't necessarily mean that just because you're good friends, that a relationship with them would work out, that they are the right person for you. So I would say, honestly, look at this person's personality, look at their character, look at their behavior. Are they really as wonderful as you think they are?
所以有时当我们经历了这一切之后，我们会在我们熟悉的事物中寻求安慰，那就是这个我们知道永远不会伤害我们的朋友。但这并不一定意味着，仅仅因为你们是好朋友，和他们的恋爱关系就能行得通，他们就是那个对的人。所以我想说，老实说，看看这个人的性格，看看他们的品格，看看他们的行为。他们真的像你想象的那么棒吗？
Do you think that your life would be perfect with this person? Or is there maybe someone else out there? And that's my second point. Give yourself some space to date elsewhere. don't date looking for distraction but to look for possibility sometimes we become you know become very obsessive when we have one person in mind and we have decided that they are the one and maybe i sound pessimistic but i think that we have more than just one person out there who is compatible with us who would make us happy so don't limit yourself before you know how they feel don't close yourself off into like
你认为有了这个人，你的生活就会完美吗？或者外面可能还有别人？这就是我的第二点。给自己一些空间去别处约会。约会不是为了寻找分心，而是为了寻找可能性。有时我们变得（你知道的）非常痴迷，当我们心里只有一个人，并且我们已经认定他们就是那个“真命天子”时。也许听起来我很悲观，但我认为在我们之外，还有不止一个人与我们合拍，能让我们快乐。所以不要在知道他们的感受之前就限制自己，不要把自己封闭在...
this space of compulsion and obsession towards this person. Keep the doors open, keep your mind open to the possibility of someone else. And don't wait for them to act or to ask you how you're feeling. Be an active player here. Get yourself some answers to that you can move forward in whatever the direction this relationship is going to take. You have to be brave to go after what you want in life in any capacity. And the answer is always going to. to be no unless you ask. In which case, yeah, you know, it might still be a no, but how can you really confirm that if you never say anything, if you never speak up? I think that speaking your truth is one of the greatest gifts that you can give yourself. If it doesn't give you a relationship,
这种对这个人的强迫和痴迷的空间中。敞开大门，对其他人可能出现的可能性保持开放的心态。不要等待他们采取行动或询问你的感受。在这里做一个积极的参与者。为自己得到一些答案，以便无论这段关系将走向何方，你都能继续前进。在生活中，无论是哪种身份，你都必须勇敢去追求你想要的东西。而且答案永远是“不”，除非你开口去问。在这种情况下，是的，你知道，它可能仍然是个“不”，但如果你从不说出口，如果你从不发声，你又怎么能真正证实这一点呢？我认为说出你的真心话是你送给自己最伟大的礼物之一。如果它没有给你带来一段恋爱关系，
at least it will give you answers. For those times when things haven't gone the way that you want them to, I cannot stress this enough, treat it like a breakup or like any other kind of romantic loss or rejection. When we shame ourselves out of big emotions, what we are enduring is called disenfranchised grief. And that is a kind of loss that is not openly acknowledged and accepted, despite it still being painful for the person experiencing it. In this case, you. Remember, it's okay to miss them. It's okay to be sad about the possibility that you saw and the future that you imagined. But it doesn't mean that they are the one. It's just the result of a bond, of attachment, of our memory flare-ups. You know, our brains are weirdly wired to bring up old
至少它会给你答案。对于那些事情没有按照你希望的方向发展的时候，我怎么强调都不为过，把它当作一次分手或任何其他类型的浪漫失落或拒绝来对待。当我们因为强烈的负面情绪而感到羞耻时，我们正在经历的被称为“被剥夺权利的悲哀”。这是一种不被公开承认和接受的失落，尽管对于经历它的那个人来说，它仍然是痛苦的。在这种情况下，就是你。记住，想念他们是没有错的。为你看得到的可能性和你想象的未来感到难过是没有错的。但这并不意味着他们就是那个人。这只是一种纽带、依恋和我们的记忆被重新点燃的结果。你知道，我们的大脑被奇怪地连线了，会在没有用处时调出旧的
memories and information when it's not useful. So it doesn't mean that you've like missed out, right? Just because you're thinking about this person, just because they're in their brain, there's no deeper meaning in that. There's no deeper fate that you've missed out on. I think it's just our natural reaction to not just rejection, but also to a disruption in our attachment. Wanting to reach out doesn't make you weak. Mourning something that never was doesn't make you crazy. I hate that word. You are just a human with a lot of big emotions.
记忆和信息。所以这并不意味着你错过了什么，对吧？仅仅因为你在想这个人，仅仅因为他们在你的脑海里，这其中并没有更深层的含义。这并不是你错过了什么更深层的命运。我认为这只是我们面对拒绝以及依恋被打断时的自然反应。想要联系并不意味着你软弱。为从未发生过的事情哀悼并不意味着你疯了。我很讨厌这个词。你只是一个有着许多强烈情感的人。
You are so sensitive and you have a lot of love to give. And I think that capacity to love others is very rare and very beautiful and should be celebrated, especially during a time where I think everyone really wants to play games and keep things close to their chest. It's honestly so radical to be so open with your love and your feelings for others. And I always think it's the people who are told they love too much, who give too much to others, who struggle the most in dating, but they are the ones who experience the deepest and most gorgeous, delicate human emotions and feelings and passion when they find the right person. This person is not the right person.
你如此敏感，你有很多爱可以给予。我认为这种爱别人的能力是非常罕见、非常美丽的，应该受到赞颂，尤其是在这样一个我认为每个人都真的很想玩游戏并把牌捂得很紧的时代。老实说，对别人坦诚你的爱和感受是非常激进的做法。我总是认为，那些被告知爱得太多、给别人付出太多的人，在约会时挣扎得最厉害，但当他们找到对的人时，他们也是体验到最深沉、最华丽、最精致的人类情感、感觉和激情的人。这个人不是对的人。
They are not the one even though you have this attachment to them, even though you have this connection. But when you do find this person who is for you, think about how amazing it's going to feel. And this current experience, what you're going through is just a chapter in your story. It's something to perhaps one day laugh about. and you'll soon really realize that it's part of the journey that gets you to where you need to be going. So in that space between now and then, do things you know will help you heal. Give yourself space to focus on your own self-growth, getting really deep into your goals, your hobbies,
尽管你对他们有这种依恋，尽管你们有这种联系，但他们不是那个人。但当你真正找到那个适合你的人时，想想那种感觉会有多棒吧。而你当前的这段经历，你所经历的一切只是你故事中的一个章节。它或许有一天会变成一个可以付诸一笑的话题，你很快就会真正意识到，这是引领你到达你该去的地方的旅程的一部分。所以在现在到那时的这段时间里，去做那些你知道能帮你疗伤的事情。给自己空间专注于自我成长，全身心投入到你的目标、爱好中，
anything to get you thinking about something other than this person. Consciously shift your thoughts from returning again and again to your friend and what could have been, to what your life will be if you take all of that energy and you spend it on yourself. I just want to say I am sending a whole lot of love. Personally, I know it's really difficult. I know that you get really, really wrapped up in what could be and what is. And it feels like you're never going to get over this person. It feels like this is going to destroy you.
做任何能让你不去想这个人的事。有意识地把你的思绪从一次又一次地回到你的朋友以及本可能发生的事情上转移开，去想想如果你把所有的精力和时间都花在自己身上，你的生活会是什么样。我只想说，我送出满满的爱。就我个人而言，我知道这真的很困难。我知道你真的会深深地纠缠于可能会发生的事情和现实中。感觉你好像永远无法走出这个人。感觉这会毁了你。
I've lived through it. It doesn't. It gets better. You will recover from this. It will just be part of this great story that is, expanding out in front of you. And maybe it does work out, in which case that's fantastic. You will join this huge group of people who do meet, you know, the loves of their lives
我经历过。它不会的。情况会好起来的。你会从这件事中恢复过来的。这只会成为在你面前展开的精彩故事的一部分。也许事情真的成功了，如果是那样的话那就太棒了。你将加入这个庞大的群体，他们确实遇到了，你知道的，他们一生的挚爱。
as friends. And I think that's just like a wonderful part of human connection and human relationships is that we have the capacity to really form these really meaningful relationships, both platonically and romantically. Just because something isn't romantic doesn't mean that it's not platonically valuable. That's something I also want you to remember. So again, lots of love, lots of healing, lots of strength. You will do what is best for you.
作为朋友。我认为这只是人类连接和人际关系中绝妙的一部分，我们有能力真正建立起这些非常有意义的关系，无论是在柏拉图式的还是浪漫的层面上。仅仅因为某些事情不是浪漫的，并不意味着它在柏拉图式上没有价值。这也是我希望你记住的一点。所以再次强调，满满的爱，满满的疗愈，满满的力量。你会做对你最好的事。
And I'm hoping that you get the outcome that you deserve. And if not, you have everything that you need to move on and to move forward. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you enjoyed it, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. make sure you're following along for when new episodes come out. There's some pretty good ones coming out soon, some special guest episodes. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you want to tell me a story about, you know, the person that you're fallen in love with who might be a friend,
我希望你能得到你应得的结果。如果没有，你拥有继续前进和向前迈进所需的一切。非常感谢大家收听本期节目。如果你喜欢它，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。确保关注我们，以便在新节目发布时收到通知。很快就会有一些相当不错的节目上线，包括一些特别嘉宾节目。如果你有节目建议，如果你想跟我讲一个关于你可能爱上了一个朋友的故事，
maybe a situation where this has worked out, please send me a DM at That Psychology Podcast. I would love to hear from you. And as always, stay kind and be gentle to yourselves. Until next time. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
也许是一个成功收场的案例，请在“That Psychology Podcast”给我发私信。我很乐意听到你的消息。一如既往，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们下期见。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加梅斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
进行一些在任何其他地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is love trapped. Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是《绝境之爱》。斯科茨代尔警方。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是有扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。在I-HeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是TWA%（注：此处原文如此）。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。